[Music]
if you like to book a hotel to take a
break you might be surprised to see that
problems follow you everywhere
just wait until you hear about all the
things that happened in hotels during
the Olympic Games in Sochi if this is
your first time visiting our channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you 10 hotels that failed so
badly it's funny
open bathrooms have you ever heard of
open bathrooms and hotels usually you
can see them in romantic getaways where
people like watching their lover taking
a bath they like this feeling of
intimacy as they have nothing to hide
and can keep an eye on each other even
when they are in the bathroom we also
don't mind having an open bathroom when
we are alone in our hotel room but
sometimes this window let us see
something really inappropriate there is
no place to hide if you want to go to
the toilet we understand that taking a
bath can be interesting for the viewer
but no one wants to see someone taking a
number 2 we also don't like the idea of
watching ourselves sitting on the throne
with a mirror Partners can be used to
seeing each other but imagine what would
happen if friends or family members have
to share this room this will be an
awkward moment for everyone and even
when they try to make this room more
private we are not satisfied by this
transparent door maybe we should just
add a Do Not Disturb sign on our door
well a friend is outside but this I need
some me time sign would make them think
that we're doing something else in the
open bathroom and sometimes there's just
no way to have any intimacy just take a
look at this open hotel room elevators
there's opposed to be so simple that
anyone who knows how to count up to 10
should be able to use them but it seems
like some people who are responsible for
elevators failed kindergarten because
they don't know how to count in some
hotels you can see random numbers placed
everywhere in the wrong order do we have
to press the number 4 to go on the 4th
floor or should we press the number 5
because that's where the number 4 is
supposed to be we'll be wasting a lot of
time in this elevator before we figure
out how it works sometimes the staff has
to make things clear when there is
number 6 where the second floor should
be but then we can see that their
instructions are even more confusing
when the number one leads to the second
and third floors but if it makes you
feel down you don't have to worry this
hotel wants to make sure that you always
go up up up anyway there is not even
enough space to think in this tiny
elevator but sometimes a missing number
is not a mistake if you go to China you
will often see that the number four is
missing in the
Eider that's because this number brings
bad luck in Asian cultures they avoid it
just like we avoid the number 13 in
America if you want to watch just one
more video the premium is the platform
where you should go get early access to
videos from the things the taco the
trendy the richest and many other great
channels in one place with ad free
browsing click this link to sign up for
the premium and get ready to binge watch
videos from your favorite channels
toilet-paper when we looked at all these
hotel fails we were surprised to see how
many people don't know how to use toilet
paper it seems like some people have
been using TP wrong for a long time
because they think that we need it to
dry ourselves off after taking a bath
and just imagine all the water that gets
on it when you take a shower and that's
why they spend so much money on toilet
paper other people think that our arms
are really long because toilet paper is
way too far away from us it is not only
one foot too far but a whole leg away
from us they also seem to think that
people in a wheelchair can easily stand
up and will only reveal their secret
when they are alone in the bathroom
fortunately other hotels make sure that
we clearly see the toilet paper above
the throne or should we call it the holy
teepee when you think that it couldn't
get worse Hotels kept surprising us just
look at this hotel maid who used a
toothbrush to fix the toilet paper we
hope that this is not the toothbrush
they expect us to use to brush our teeth
and this guy who was responsible for
changing the toilet paper just used the
wrong hole we bet that his girlfriend is
not happy when he accidentally does this
at home rules when we book a hotel it is
usually because we want to take a break
during our vacations but some hotels
don't seem to understand that because
they keep telling us about their rules
and some of them are actually hilarious
just take a look at this one that
doesn't make sense there is a cigarette
ashtray that says no smoking it is just
like this fire escape that you can't use
in case of fire some hotels don't want
you to enjoy your trip with your partner
as they say that the beds are only for
one person others have rules that we
understand but no one usually makes a
sign to tell us about that it includes
don't fart in the elevator don't dump in
the pool and don't vomit in the sauna it
seems like they made this rule because
people used to do that before just look
at this sign from a hotel who had a
problem with their pool or should we say
their poop but this last hotel
is the one that surprised us the most
recommendations include don't bring your
value things avoid accidents don't drink
too much don't go to the dark place and
more if we ever see this we would
immediately cancel our reservation and
booked another hotel it would be safer
to live on the street and we wouldn't
have to pay anything doors and windows
humans have been using doors and windows
for thousands of years so we thought
that people from the 21st century would
understand how it works but it is not
always the case some hotels want to save
money on doors instead of having one for
the Wardrobe and one for the bathroom
you have to use the same for both so
anytime someone has to go to the toilet
you have to look at the mess in the
wardrobe which is not really fun to see
there are also people who don't know
about the importance of safety it's
impossible to lock those doors properly
and we can say that those who have to
use it are really unlucky then there's
the window these people had the chance
to look at a construction site from
their bedroom window
but it is not as bad as people who have
to look at a wall and it just got worse
when we saw that someone actually put a
window that leads directly into the
hallway no that's worse than not being
able to lock your door but sometimes you
wish that door could open during the
Olympics a bobsledder was stuck in the
bathroom for an hour after taking a
shower he didn't have a phone a towel or
even any clothes to wear so he decided
to use his bobsled push to make a big
hole in it and guess what three days
after he got stuck in the elevator of
the same hotel decorations hotel rooms
are not known for having the best
decorations but these ones are so bad
that they kept surprising us we already
talked about problems with windows and
this time they forgot to add one they
just randomly added some curtains on the
wall to give hope to the customers we
don't know which is worse but we think
that these curtains painted on the wall
are a pretty big fail too and don't
think that this hotel is the only one
that uses paint to fix their problems
when they don't have enough money to buy
furniture and decorations they just
paint it on the wall talking about
paintings you probably know that hotels
buy a lot of the same decorations and
put them in different rooms but it is
the first time that we see the two same
pictures next to each other in the same
hotel room it looks like someone just
used the cheapest painting while playing
The Sims to have a better environment or
would you like this painting inspired by
wet hair on the shower wall instead we
are not sure about that anything can be
an inspiration for decorations just look
at this hotel in Asia that used
random letters from the Latin alphabet
on the wall and when you think that
hotel can't feel harder than that they
found a way to surprise us once again
furniture some things are really
important like security and intimacy and
some fails just make us laugh when it is
about toilet paper and decorations but
even when it comes to really basic
things hotels just keep failing once
again this hotel probably said on their
website that they offered a king-sized
bed but they forgot to say that they
only had a double size mattress you
can't say that they lied or would you
like to sleep next to samuel l.jackson
this one is not too bad but just wait
until you see what someone found in
their bed the previous customer left a
note saying if you're reading this then
housekeeping did not change your sheets
hotel rooms also cheat when it comes to
furniture and people end up working on
the tiniest little desk and sometimes
they just don't even have access to
furniture and appliances just look at
this fridge placed way too high on the
counter this mini fridge would be cool
if only we could open the door and
sometimes things just get ridiculous
when only Superman has access to this
little living room or would you like a
room under construction instead hotels
know that they can lie as much as they
want to travelers they only discover
their mistakes when it's too late to
book another room this is how they are
left with a vacation that is worth the
low price that they paid outside we had
enough of drama let's go outside and
enjoy the fresh air what could go wrong
out there
if your hotel looks like this before you
enter you should probably try to find a
room somewhere else as soon as possible
it seems like it was too hot in this
hotel and the sign literally took on
fire anyway you might not even get the
chance to enter as these stairs are
leading to nowhere let's take a break
and relax by the pool instead
unfortunately we don't think that this
one is appropriate for kids when we see
its shape we don't have to tell you what
it is those who have a dirty mind can
easily see it but no matter what this
grown-up man seems to be enjoying the
figurehead of the pirate ship
everything is somatic in these hotels
when we see these bushes but this is
better than what we can find in other
motels as some pools are definitely
closed unless you're looking for
something a little harder than water
maybe we should just stay inside anyway
there's a bear in this area but we think
that we're even more terrified by this
frozen door no matter where we go hotel
fails follow us everywhere would it be
better if we travel to another country
Olympics in Sochi during the Olympics in
2014
thousands of people traveled to Russia
to see the athletes in action
unfortunately some of the best hotels
were taken and it means that many people
had to look for something cheaper and it
led to the most hilarious consequences
as we had the chance to see on Twitter
someone complained that the reception in
his hotel had no floor but at least
there was a welcoming picture of Putin
another man found out that there was no
lobby at all in his hotel so he had to
go to the owner's bedroom to check in a
woman also said that her hotel had no
water if it was restored the front desk
told her not to use it on her face
because it contained something really
dangerous do you want to hear more
hotels in Sochi just keep failing at
everything a man said that there was no
internet in his room and another one
found out that it was dangling from the
ceiling Russians also don't have the
chance to have any intimacy some people
don't have any doorknob on their door
but instead they have three light bulbs
and when something is not missing things
just keep breaking as the light fixture
falls from the ceiling and the curtains
don't want to be a part of this world
anymore at least the Olympic Games were
amazing
so we'll forgive Russia for these little
mistakes toilets if there is one thing
that we will remember from Russia during
the Olympics
it's the toilets you might think that
you have already seen enough but it just
keeps getting worse
toilets are supposed to be intimate but
it seems like Sochi didn't get the memo
when someone found out that there were
two toilets next to each other in the
same room this topic became more popular
than a winner of the gold medal and we
found out that they were not the only
two toilets like this not only in Sochi
but all around the world people have the
chance to do a number two with their
friends girls who like to go to the
bathroom together would love to see that
or if there is only one toilet they can
also wait in line well everyone is
watching what someone is doing on the
throne but that's not the only crazy
thing that people saw in Russia there is
also a strict code of conduct on how to
use the bathroom including not to go
fishing in the toilet some people have
also been told to put the toilet paper
in a bin after using it we don't know
who will be cleaning this but they
probably regret telling people to do
that we don't know exactly where this is
from but we bet that some of these
unusual Thrones were found in hotels -
have you ever seen a funny FAIL in a
hotel don't be shy to tell us what
happened in the comment section below
and that's it for 10 hotels that filled
so badly it's funny for more stories
like this make sure you watch 10
easiest things people have done on
planes thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]